hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde ich war mal wieder in den weiten
des internets unterwegs und habe mir
dort einige ebay kleinanzeigen fällt
zusammen gesucht wo ich mir einfach
wieder gedacht habe wie kann man so
wenig gehirnzellen besitzen
beispielsweise hier da schreibt nämlich
immer ein hallo ja versandkosten wären
wahrscheinlich so bei 7 euro oder so hat
die preise nicht im kopf ok ich muss
aber noch warten ich bekomme diesen
monat noch taschengeld und nächsten
monat auch ich verkaufe das für meine
freunde und die will das geld möglichst
bald haben sorry schau doch einfach noch
mal rein wenn du das geld hast gibt ja
ganz viele angebote
okay okay lass mich überzeugt ich
schicke dir an welche adresse soll ich
schicken jonas bring aber noch heute zur
post ok deine eltern sind also michaela
und oli die stehen im telefonbuch was
die wohl dazu sagen dass du fremde leute
im internet beleidigt das war nicht so
gemeint
das war mein kleiner bruder richtig halo
ist der kleine bruder ja das war ich
[Musik]
immer noch kaputt
als nächstes verkaufte jemand eine power
bank auf ebay mit der du halt dein handy
laden kann
er schreibt allerdings in den titel der
anzeige ich verkaufe ein power bank geht
ein bahnfrei punkt in weißpunkt 70 euro
bei 100 prozentig dieser kleine junge
der gerade das dingens kaufen wollte und
ihr verkauft jemand sonnenblenden verein
bmw e36 und einkäufer fragt hallo noch
da noch das sorry ja klar haben sie
interesse schiebt ihr verdammten den
ersten menschen falsche chat sorry muss
er eine krasse preisverhandlung sein
worum geht es denn auto fliegen wird
[Applaus]
hier verkauft jemand einen samsung
galaxy s 7 edge ein interessent fragt
den verkäufer hallo was es 50 - 20 euro
daraufhin antwortet der verkäufer
natürlich 30 euro ok dann 30 euro
adresse 140 möchte ich für das handy
haben wie in der anzeige zu spät 30 war
die letzte angeboten netter versuch
brauche adresse 30 euro angebot ist
bindend adresse geben sonst brief von
anwalt
ich würde - steht nicht an wiese und ich
anstatt mit aussteht anwalt konnten wir
allerdings hier zum nächsten ebay feld
unterschreibt hat eine person dort das
planschbecken ist kaputt jetzt war ganz
ruhig es war bisher immer dicht es
verliert aber ständig luft an dem
aufblasen teil ventil ist das richtig
verschlossen fest reindrücken ich habe
da kreppband rom gewickelt aber hält
nicht wenn man wasser rein tut luft geht
raus ist der plastik noble fest drin wo
nach der am ventil aufblasen dann direkt
den plastik stoppuhr eindrücken der im
ventil dranhängt dann bleibt die luft
drin so geht's ja haben sie noch nie
etwas aufgeblasen ein boot oder die
schwimmflügel ihrer kinder oder sowas
hab keine kinder das ding ist zum bier
kühlen menschen ziemlich abstoßend
verkauft jemand einen selbständigen
hamster auf ebay und schreibt in die
beschreibung erst viel erfolgreicher als
ich und betreibt eine eigene bar
meine frau macht auch schon auge auf ihn
ich muss mich von ihm trennen bevor die
situation eskaliert dass
ja
beeindruckt mich irgendwie mittlerweile
gar nicht mehr auf die welt kommen
damit doch whatsapp gehen ja wirklich ja
kann man okay
als nächstes verschenkt eine person auf
ebay 2020 als aufblasbare luftballons
und sie schreibt dazu verschenkt werden
ja vier aufblasbare ziffern ideal für
silvester 2200 wahlweise auch für einen
22 geburtstag oder wenn die oma 200 wird
oder als geschenk wenn sie zwei nullen
in ihrem freundeskreis haben um ihnen
dies auf entspannten wege zu zeigen
abzuholen in langen
sich wenn die oma 200 jahre alt wird
hier schreibt marvin einem käufer dass
er einen euro zurücküberwiesen hat da er
doch online frankieren konnte und der
käufer antwortete daraufhin danke fand
die ehrlichkeit hinter der
rücküberweisung von dem ein euro so gut
dass ich ihnen mal vier euro überwiesen
habe in nächster dollar oder was ich
sonst so gerne kleines essen geht auf
mich ihren mann
es gibt auch echt coole ebay sales
und dann gibt's kolumbianischen schnee
ich habe die wenigsten wissen was damit
gemeint ist das horror haus muss weg
egal was man macht man macht es falsch
ist eigentlich noch gut in schuss vor
einigen jahren wurde einiges renoviert
aber dann geht man vor die tür und wird
angesehen bekommt von einkommen und wird
so angesehen als hätte man nicht alles
in butter gekauft seit kurzem habe ich
das gefühl das ist meine freude meint es
ist der wind jaja der wind der wind
ziegel nach einem ja ja ich halte es
nicht mehr aus ich muss hier weg ich
kratze ort geschrieben ich hier verkauft
jemand gewichte für arme und beine oder
interessant schreibt ihm ist da sand und
ab leiterin hallo und guten tag das
anderen liebe grüße schade gewichtes
gewicht nein
sand ist zu leicht pro
ein kilo sand ist genau das gleiche wie
ein kilo blei
die gesündere die das da gefragt hast du
kleiner verkauft jemand einen
benzinkanister und ein interessent
schreibt dem verkäufer bitte mit versand
ich bezahle auch mit paypal tut mir leid
ich habe kein paypal ich gehe jetzt
packen und wenn ich damit fertig bin
haben sie sich ein paypal konto angelegt
man ich durfte immer mehr in diese
nordische hamburger sprache ab der
verkauft jemand einen kunstleder
bürostuhl und schreibe 90 wird in stufe
20 euro nehmen der verkäufer schreibt er
allerdings hatten wir zu wenig
der stuhl steht doch mit 20 euro
festpreis in der anzeige ja aber die
anzeige ist doch schon seit über einem
monat online ändern sich die preise dann
nämlich was ist das denn für mit logik
aus welchem grund sollte der studien
jetzt plötzlich teurer sein als vor
allem monat inflation
er hat halt aber gar nicht mal pro
minute allerdings meine lieben freunde
zu einigen ebay anzeigen mir zugesandt
wurden wo einfach beispielsweise ich als
meerschweinchen verkauft wurde oder auch
hier eine smiley stehlampe dann auch
beispielsweise dass hier ein buch namens
der junge der träume schenkt mit mir auf
dem cover drauf oder auch das hier ist
einfach eine luca rolex
ich weiß nicht ob ich klatschen oder
weinen soll weil es auf der einen seite
mega kreative auf der anderen seite
nein da kommt nichts
hier verkauft jemand eine formschöne und
gepflegte couch ein interessent schreibt
ihm wow das ist nicht so weit weg von
uns vielleicht kann mir komplett zu fuß
schleppen wegen der planung könntest mir
bitte sagen die schwer die beiden teile
sind weil man kann es in zwei stücke
teilen und trennen oder das schau ich
heute abend nach wenn ich wieder eine
wohnung bin melde mich dann später danke
simon die couch kann man in drei teile
trennen da man den extra schlaf kasten
noch herausnehmen kann wie schwer die
teile genau sind kann ich nicht sagen
man bekommt sie auf jeden fall zu zweit
durch die wohnung getragen aber meine
freundin und ich bezweifeln etwas das
man die länger als 100 meter getragen
bekommt ohne am nächsten tag tierischen
muskelkater zu haben wie weit wo dir
denn entfernt falls ihr rollbretter
haben solltet könnte das die sache
natürlich vereinfachen
20 minuten zu fuß der plan ist von netto
bzw
rewe zwei einkaufswagen auszuleihen
danke für die antwort simon wenn ihr die
20 minuten mit den einkaufswagen die
couch transportieren wollte
beziehungsweise könnt könnt ihr das
natürlich machen und die haben das
gemacht und so sah das ganze auf
ja
unter dieser extrem dumm aktion will ich
mich bis heute wieder noch verabschieden
meine lieben freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann einen daumen runter
video das schreiben in die kommentare
was ich morgen hochladen sollen
abonniert main kanal jetzt noch kein
teil der doku seit und wenn ihr jetzt
nichts mehr zu tun haben solltet dick
und doof der beschissenen podcast der
welt kam heute wollen wir zwei in diesem
jahr aus auch spotify gern anhören
als wohl
[Musik]